bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france ces annonces du
gouvernement pour le plan de
déconfinement est ce qu'elle vous semble
cohérente d'un point de vue médical
je pense que le calendrier est assez bon
parce que effectivement le 11 mai on
sera dans une situation sera tout à fait
circulera très peu le confinement il
aura été efficace à peu près dans toutes
les zones en france
en revanche je pense qu'il n'y a pas eu
suffisamment de détails sur la
répartition du risque dans la population
sur le fait que à partir du 11 mai le
virus va forcément vous circulez il va
falloir qu'il y ait des gens en
particulier les gens les plus âgés ceux
qui ont des facteurs de risques qui vont
devoir faire plus attention que les
autres ça je trouve que ça a été trop
absent du discours d'hier les prévisions
justement ce qui concerne la circulation
du virus après le 11 mai le virus il va
recirculer ça c'est sûr et certain cédé
0 loi déjà en allemagne et ensuite la
rapidité de la circulation du virus
dépendra des mesures et de la manière
dont les applique
c'est à dire la distanciation physique
le port du masque moment est transports
en commun je pas sûr que ces accords a
le plus d'impact
et puis aussi avec elle passée de le
testing corrao je pense un impact limité
je pense que c'est vraiment la
distanciation physique qui va jouer
c'est la manière dont la société va
reprendre vie et plus aura des contacts
à témoin est protégé et plus ça ira vite
mais quoi qu'il arrive il y aura une
reprise l'épidémie qu'après le 11 mai
c'est pour ça qu'il faut absolument que
les gens fragiles fasse attention à
partir du lendemain
je disais au début de ce journal qu'il
fallait évidemment regarder les chiffres
voir l'évolution justement de cette
épidémie est ce qu'on sera prêts selon
vous le
11 mai pour des consignes et je vous le
dis sur le plan logistique sans le condé
les masques les gens je crois qu'ils ont
été formés à la distanciation physique
donc il voit très bien ce que c'est je
crois que les entreprises sont en train
de se préparer
en particulier ils font des alertes sur
les gens qui sont en situation qui ont
une maladie chronique ce genre de choses
pour essayer de les laisser au maximum
noté trahi je pense qu'on sera prêt
comme je vous dis ça va vraiment
dépendre de la manière dont sont
organisés les différentes les
différentes communes les différentes
régions les différentes entreprises
il va vraiment falloir mettre en place
des procédures pour que les gens
fragiles fasse attention messieurs on
est prêt il ya aucune raison d'attendre
en dehors de ça ça il ya beaucoup
beaucoup d'inquiétudes sur notamment le
la disposition des masques la mise à
disposition que ces masques pour le
grand public les tests aussi massif et
puis aussi le retour de certains
écoliers sur les bancs de l'école là
encore beaucoup de craintes il ya cette
étude au royaume uni en france sur de
possibles liens entre la pandémie de
coronavirus est une maladie grave qui
touche un certain nombre d'enfants une
maladie similaire à celle que l'on
appelle kawasaki alors de quoi s'agit-il
est ce que vous vous avez des
informations
bages et les quelques informations
effectivement les médecins anglais au
début qui ont rapporté effectivement
quelque chose qui ressemble à un
syndrome post inflammatoires qu'est la
maladie de kawasaki qu est la plus
fréquente au assez fréquentes au japon
et un peu moins dans les pays dans les
pays d'europe et aux etats unis
en fait ce qu'il faut bien comprendre
c'est une maladie qui est générée par
l'immunité des enfants après une
inflexion donc c'est pas étonnant
finalement qu'on la voit arriver après
la vague épidémique
pour l'instant c'est rarissime mais
c'est vraiment quelque chose qui va
falloir surveiller de très près
effectivement il ya eu une quinzaine de
cas qui ont été rapportés dans les 3
bronze aux pipots à pédiatrique par
exemple et sur les décès
dion du gouvernement sont ce retour des
écoliers à l'école qu'en pensez vous je
pense que c'est quelque chose qui était
tout à fait rationnel dans la mesure où
et les enfants semblaient n'avoir aucun
risque et toutes les études montraient
qu'ils transmettent d'assez peu donc je
pense que la réouverture des écoles
on sait tous les effets secondaires du
confinement chez les enfants étaient
vraiment une très bonne décision
il faut réfléchir à ce qu'on est en
train de voir si c'est mieux car dit
chez les enfants qu'on est en train de
de conté il y en a vraiment très peu et
pour l'instant à se sont toutes bien
terminé mais voir que les capacités de
réanimation pour les enfants ils sont
assez faibles
ça c'est vraiment quelque chose qui va
vouloir surveiller de très près jusqu'au
11 mai pour se terminer sur les besoins
laeremans du système hospitalier
parce que vous avez eu des réponses hier
lors de cette sortie du premier ministre
moi je dois dire que là dessus je pense
que les services hospitaliers français
vont vite se retrouve 3e trouvé débordé
puisque je vous le dis on sait que le
virus va recirculer et pour l'instant il
n'y a rien de concret qui a annoncé pour
protéger les gens qui risquent de finir
en réanimation à mon avis aujourd'hui à
rien de concret qui a qui permettra
d'éviter et que le service que les
services hospitaliers se retrouve
débordée je ne crois pas que une
stratégie départementale permettra
d'éviter ça je pense que ça n'aura aucun
impact
il suffit juste c'est que c'est vraiment
très simple si les gens peuvent se
déplacer à 100 km eh bien vous fait 100
km sans qu'il aurait 100 km et l'idée
avant le virus circule à travers les
frontières départementales
donc je pense que ça assez peu de sens
si je sais pas très bien quel est le
rationnel de ceux de co2 rouge et de ses
zones vertes aimerait bien comprendre
mais merci beaucoup à vous martin
blachier je rappelle que vous êtes
médecin des régions de public l
expertise merci